[Musik]
die erste große liebe sie trifft
heimteams das herz und prägt sich die
vrm pc experten an gott viele fans
begleitet die erinnerungs level an aber
nur wenige
denn deren erste liga zweite chance erst
viel später
die geschichten sind bester stoff für
liebesfilm und 700 uhr live auf umweg
die geschichte zeigen
sogar eine frühe märz das mit seiner
gehört meines lebens spricht rechnung
machen zum beispiel doris unter hermann
südostschweiz 50 jahre ist es her da
hermann hätte tauchsport racine rallye
fest auch wenn sich vier jahre lang
nicht erwidert werden
claudia und epeat sie treffen sich vor
28 jahren auf samos affäre elia bio die
zukunft groß ist distanz und große
zweifel dass die labile bayerisch und
monika und der erich vor 240 jahren
solothurn hierbei auf der erste blick
oder erich sucht des glücks italien und
merkt nicht dass es eigentlich schon
gefunden hätten und wie ihres lebens
projekt
[Musik]
als bub und mädchen von zehn lenzen hegt
mir gefühle füreinander klare grenzen
ich fühlte mich trotz meiner
jugendlichkeit im siebten himmel
die zukunft war er noch soweit
geschichte vor dem gedicht die
erzählerin hütz jwb ist als mächtiges
gefühl sie macht sogar als polizisten
dichter sind bei der notrufzentrale der
kantonspolizei thurgau per se negativ
romantischen ort aber da hat riskio der
hermann merz nacht für nacht lang wache
und immer dann wenn es ruhig bleiben ist
bei der platz um seinen eigenen gefühle
und gedanken und der gedanke die renten
immer wieder zu einer frau treibt
nämlich zu der doris day doris wo ihm
schon in der primarschule der hauptrolle
doris harmonieren können vergessen
sie ist sehr fröhlich sie sich
intelligenz sieht eigentlich bist und
siehst leidlich sie nicht nur in der
klasse schüler anderer klassen
[Musik]
in sure you say me so früh klinge hatte
hermann somit sein klient deckt ums herz
verloren
doris sie ist aufgeweckt michael stock
gern im mittelpunkt ganz anders da
hermann bayerischen ruhiger surenburg
ich hab ihm trost ist dass es gibt in
gent und dienstpläne messe augsburg
person jetzt damit mit - und das weiß
ich warum bin ich nervös wenn ich
ehrlich bin weil es für claire biggs ist
amazon
am hermann sie ältere 1 rüdlingen
erbitte metzgerei als restaurant der
herr man muss viel die helfen die beide
schuhe strom celtics
ich habe mich erinnere dass sich mutter
sowie gebracht hat als wir einmal zu der
familie des restaurants inc usa amazon
dick ja das ist das ist das highlight
und das zeigt mir sehr sehr viel länger
in danzig
mit sägen um nach und rote backen über
um alles gegen uns ganz hilfreich
[Musik]
klassische unschuldige erste liebe und
der hermann spielerisch getraut sich
notorisch zeigen dass sie gern hat er
machte mit dem geschenk
sicherlich sind mit farbigen weckruf für
sich gesehen und ich also immer gerne
schmuck empfindsamkeit gesehen da sah
ich lisbeth
mit einem kettchen in silbernen pflanzen
kleine wappen rundeten ab das ganze
wollte ich jeden moment bei dir sein
wir vermitteln ich bin nicht von einer
anderen große liebe vor 240 jahren im
lehrerseminar unterfangen
[Musik]
wie sie blick haben sich getroffen
das ist das ist sehr schön bin natürlich
machen wie zufällig und den bisschen
länger verweilen
[Musik]
sie wird nicola und dass ich sie liebe
auf den ersten blick sehr sehr heiß ganz
groß kosten
beide jetzt richtig verwischt aber der
erste schritt machen getraute sich nicht
bis zum studenten bald tag sagte er ich
seine chance endlich ein paar mal
getroffen
das ist gut so haben wir morgen entlang
und leiterin monika ich habe ja gemerkt
dass ich den wenig das läuft das denn
irgendwie irgendwann mal den hund in der
gemerkt dass rheinmetall gegangen ist
um dennoch nicht merkt dass plötzlich
die strecke und ich kann ihnen aber auch
wieder langsam im halo betrete ich
schaue mir einen balkon
also wirklich sehr sehr gewillt ist die
caritas getrieben am schluss nicht dass
ich so ein erfüllender moment ich sie
von meinen wunsch
[Musik]
am bau bringt sich die beiden schnell
löschen
den größeren karte das ist ziemlich
glücklich mit den tanz nach der
zustellung hast und es werden immer
wieder tanzen für klima und das hat er
sich christa einmal unternehmen wieder
ich hoffe also dass man die puppen der
bin ich daheim ist es passiert war
wirklich gerade bist für mich für
android-apps pack mit einem gefühl ich
habe mich gar nicht
[Musik]
griechenland so 1986 meer sonne strand
richtig stimmig 5 läuft ein schwedisches
student mit griechischen wurzeln
jobsuche ist im heimatland aus
winterthur ist griechenland in den
ferien wieder open air disco kommt alles
natürlich dann und dann ja also ich sehe
einfach so die studie
[Musik]
nicht hätte ich dann so stark dass wir
so im blick und der zweifaller zeigen
die quelle dass man in der nähe von
langstrasse sind
denn haben wir so viel methan oder click
los aber das tat er sprach der
handwerkliche können irgendwie ordner
und dann eine denkt so etwas machen dass
das doch kilometer fahren und dann an
absolute dürfe frau bestellt also und in
einem neuen unternehmen ist im nächsten
langsam agiert nimmt sein und fordert
claudia zum tanzen auf
was ich so eine paradoxie von george
michael wo das leder krone hat hat man
sich da man ist mir nach hause und dann
wirklich alle kondome hat einfach nie
existiert
[Musik]
wir können rundum kalt und weiß nicht
passieren erhalten wie es mit märkten
kino ist weitgehend sony war es ist ein
ruhe stau also ich wirklich passiert
deshalb auch so
[Musik]
ja
der nächste tag sind die beiden
zehnjährigen ständig therapie zeigte
claudia heimat chemie stimmt claudia
merkt schnell dass das mädel die werden
als vergänglichen ferien flirt darum
versucht sie die stachen empfindet unter
druck
[Musik]
sony hat dann versucht gefühl dort nicht
allzu fest und will mir ja dein gewissen
billig reisen ab und dann ist das doch
ist alles wieder verdienen
zwei wochen dauert die wunderbare so
mobil wie dein sim ferien fertig claudia
muss abschied nehmen von griechenlands
und die dachse verschwinde ich habe
diesen trend so kaufte das harmlose und
sie hat ja es ist halt schwierig weil
nordbank hat ja kurz danach dann nach
deren abriss familie gott das irgendwie
recht aber jedes mal merkte spiel
gehalten
wenig später ich bin von der schweiz ich
gott nötig auch viel 2000
die schweiz zurück in die realität
zurück in der politik wieder claudia
sind die dose kilometer distanz xing
motionär trend aber diesen andere
baustellen sich plötzlich frage dass mit
dem es wirklich zukunft in china wie
stark und wie jeder der ersten
simulation zunächst definitiv festlegen
und das auch uns das auch bieten ist
eine andere bahn
plötzlich hört zu ziehen und vernunft
siegt
dann kann der tag an dem eine welt
zerbrach
da gab es mir das kettchen zurück weißt
du wie das stark tief in mein herz hören
der klinge seelenschmerz du hattest dich
entschieden war es damals dein herz
ich bin sehr folgsam leidlich see und
han wähle meine ältere erlebt sind sie
und erwartungen erfüllt und derartige
sinkt sie das meer
liebe freundschaft verschiebt aufs
erwachsenenalter
da hab ich was mir schwerer otto das
heißt das was mir sind drei erhielt die
familie jetzt noch so viel später ist
dass sonnen schlimm um ängste haben
jahrgang
am hermann sind fühlen sich nie erlebt
doris wieder still und auf distanz doris
hat entschieden dass es nicht auf sie
kann aber gewiss dass ich am hermann
das habe ich immer gespürt barriere
aussehen anständige gut erzogene
maximale brander bedrängt
und hätte eigentlich ist dadurch sehr
klickten
abrechnen
wir können
[Musik]
monika und erich marx gegenteil sie
stürzen
die beiden tiere bezirk falls labour der
sibe school ist vieles möglich
[Musik]
kindergärten und der lehrer müsse die
freiheit im alltag und weisen den finder
als freunde sind mir so eine kita als
kurz kühl sicherheit
monika und erich bauer hat sich als
gemeinsames leben nach der ausbildung
sichert ihre erste gemeinsame wohnung
monika fand begeisterte alle
schiedsrichter gewirkt so alles wird der
selbermacher der lampe schäden selber
gemacht und polster für den studien ist
nicht alles als erste maschine kauft und
hinten herrschte schafik sie war nicht
verdient als die bernina also dorthin
eigentliche problem angefangen
ich bin den schule roxy und haben mit
eine politische sache befassen
und dass er viel klasse und sie hat ja
beginnen jetzt quasi den sport
[Musik]
findet er sich festlege bislang war das
ist mir alles schnell schnell und ich
habe gesagt ich kann nicht etwas aber
ich einen film der bis zu 8
ob sie suri schliesst sich der erich
jedes jahr die bürgerinitiativen und
kämpft gegen atomkraft wäre der junge
lehrer wird ist innenansichten radikales
flüge das fleisch essen
das militär das spiel zu tun
[Musik]
ich habe ganz große starke uns freiheit
ganz stark für hobby mehr ich ganz fest
aus alle musiker mal alles angesehen
ich bin nun steht die teils sie in der
partnerschaft und und das ist dass die
beziehungen durch eine periode lang
gratis
[Musik]
trotz viel liebe noch fünf jürgen peter
monika unterricht erwarteten ausland
[Musik]
griechenland und simuliert wie sind
wieder claudia auch noch 8 20 jahre
immer noch präsent
briefe von peta hat sie wie einen schatz
sie der schachtel
[Musik]
die 4
als vor tiefer der claudia und empfiehlt
auf samos clean auch ihren preis
hattrick schreibe ich weiß nur dass
leute mir im zimmer hof mit klarheit und
ich sehe dass luschkow er sich richtig
krank will er hat mir mal ihre bisherige
dem zimmer mit traurigen nachricht auf
eine seite von mir hinterland dann habe
ich genau gewusst was ist sie nicht
hilft und die luft pusten natürlich
genial ich sehe also komplettieren
osterferien geschrieben auf samos sechs
gleich ohne claudia und er vermisse sie
und die gemeinsame zeit enorm
[Musik]
weder hätte people am standort aus der
schweiz müsse weiter freut freude also
klar irgendwie rosarote brille vom
schlage sie typisch weiblich oder ich
bin glaube ich dass jetzt sie vom
schäferhof dann ist es der durch meine
mutter hat nie durchgemacht so ist das
immer der fall b jaja motto richtig
heilige südländische familie die ich so
wirklich überhaupt ab
der brief ist stocksauer schrieben sich
die beiden regelmäßig über monate gefühl
für einen flachen trotz der distanz
nicht ab im gegenteil
der ton zwischen ihnen wird in nico und
vertrauter
[Musik]
der look sofort können sie von einem
freund bei claudia absurd schwede
erzielte schweiz beide lernt welt vom
andere kennen und können sich beide
bieten
aber die gemeinsame zieht es jedes mal
beschränkt und immer wieder wenn sie
sich trennen
die sich immer von politik sie man hat
sehr schön kann und wenn der abstieg ist
so ein los sie so einen los bis zum
nächsten mal
sie lebe ich meine redet da noch von
ried spanne von hochrhein sondern sind
ein monat fegt sie über brücke ich jetzt
wieder so wie immer stand wieder die
zeit
es ist so viel höhere tv ist beide muss
glücklich über seine wurzeln euro
carrera und auswandern
die stücke wurden große schritt sorgt
für claudia formates in die heimat und
züchtet schweiz
ist denn auch der vorstand das ist fast
unwirklich oder bis glaubt und und er
ist eigentlich mit 2
[Musik]
das große glück dauert aber nicht lange
der alltag ist schwierig die pfadfinder
das symbol für die techniker in der
schweiz darstellen wie honig er hatte
seine freundin am 10
bis am abend heiko bin ich bin mit taxi
das hat ihnen ihr korn leben wirklich
also kann ich nicht sagen depressiv
sowjetischen aber dann wirklich null
bock
[Musik]
lebeck ataxie sie hat mir in allen
belangen unterstützt aber das nützt sie
ja nicht wenn wenn wenn wenn keine
arbeitspapiere chance gibt
[Musik]
noch fünf minute markt nehme er will
wieder reif schweden bäck von winterthur
gerade noch dank der typischen also er
merkt dass es dort doch noch mit mir
oder und und ja mir ist natürlich dass
einige coole gegangen
wie kollege du sie kilometer zwischen
den beiden und wieder vor allem elend
sucht sie trost wie man andere mal
rapid wiederum aus schweden erlitt
meldet sich bitte claudia plötzlich eine
stimme eines hatte zur folge dass dann
der andere telefon abgehört ist sehr
unglücklich zu machen die telekom nimmt
ab und dann sage ich ja hallo sagen so
da ist der steigende claudia am telefon
joschi spannend ok
und dann habe ich gesagt ja ich sehe es
einfach nicht mehr mit der zahl
[Musik]
der narr nix also nur dann hat der
schecks das halt so wälder oder die
größe lebe ich halt russland schloss
fertig kopiert wird mit der tatsache
konfrontiert
er glaubt nicht dass claudia gehört
manager standortwahl kindergärtnerin
monika sich entscheiden noch nie ist
monika mit liebenzell kindergärten
revolte mährischen stars ihre zweite
große liebe mit der indisch für sie aber
häufig
[Musik]
in der liebe zu mehr ich einfach gemerkt
habe ich will nicht dass sie so ich will
dass es ratsam sie das will ich will mit
der zehnte santa monica hat wunderbar
sie wie sie leibt erfüllt und
selbstbestimmt
der eric abel ist nun auf der suche nach
dem lebenssinn alles bürgerliche
schreckt ihn ab herbst mit honig und dem
gericht und der trifft man eine seite
und damit meine zeit als der ta nicht
merkt
und ich mache das alle und das ist quasi
das ziel
das ist für mich wie nicht gegangen
ich habe merke ich will ich will und
kann optional und reform
der erich träumt vom us wanderer und so
stellt er hat monika ford wahl entweder
metro oder heizung geblieben
monika entscheidet sich fürs bliebe so
marschierte er ich allein los ohne plan
sind die große liebe leute hinter sich
flucht ganz klar also derzeit nicht
gewusst dass sie mich liebt und ich habe
gewusst dass ich sie liebe
aber der hype ist mit bringen etwas
nicht oder ich bringe das nicht auf eine
lappalie ebene
ich muss jetzt die flucht traten am
morgen geheißen ich weiß nur noch dass
er den weg ist und sind dennoch sich
leider gesehen und taxi
[Musik]
ich bin ich dankbar jetzt sieht sich auf
den oberbayern credo und und dali
energie gott von mir weg
und die braucht einfach bis wieder rund
auf dem konto
der erich lauf wie sieht aus ghana
der befindet deren abgeschickte hof und
ballt sich als selbstversorger
neuenstein zu frau kennen und heiratet
bald für ihn folgte neuer
lebensabschnitt
[Musik]
weit weg von monika sie stoffen hof im
solothurnischen zurückblieben und musst
lernen umgang mit dem gedanken das erste
mal vor ihrem leben
gegen sie entschieden hat das wäre als
ob sie mit der erste große liebe und
natürlich gutes leben doch neue menschen
neue beziehungen geortet und gründete
familie dass die meisten aber geschichte
bitte bis vor der ersten liga
sie lauten 2 aufzuschieben aber ganz
vergessen lassen sich nun also erlebte
hermann merz und die standzeit oder weg
oder der jurist mitverfolgt und jetzt
schickt ihre zeichen
[Musik]
hielt sich die sehnsucht nicht länger
aus so schickte ich dir blumen
du hattest nicht dass welchem haus wo
sich immer mehr in xi und auch später
noch während dem ich wieder ineinander
bezirks ii bin kann ich mir den mann als
herz gefasst weil wenn ich dich so groß
sie sich an ihren strauß rosen schickt
aber seine größte problem das 16
[Musik]
ich bediene pushen oder hat sie nicht
stören
das ist da noch der trend sich weg vom
hermann und doris herrmann macht
karriere bitte kantonspolizei thurgau
meter ist er lang mit hundeführer mit
einer 20 und gründete familie
[Musik]
aber seine erste liebe doris vergisst
umhüllt
eine verletzte stroese wirklich fahren
da erinnere dass ich den hausruck blüte
im blumenladen und trockener werdenden
strecke toxisch und könne oder nicht
doris macht nach der chemie und wird
sie ortet ein us student aus tschechien
und komplett auf aber so richtig glauben
[Musik]
will zu uns führt roger h und für da
sich alles andere von baltic sea und den
sinn kindheit familie k
und noch grundsätze oder vollständige
vom inneren familie widmen egal was
passiert
dahinter gefühl zum hermannplatz
ecke von herzig sicher immer führte
hermine serie
ich denke dass ich aus vernunftsgründen
ist das einfache zur schlossen sich die
perlen in einem umschlag verschloss
anderen hinzu meine managerin
wo einfach gewartet hat bis es endlich
wieder geöffnet wird
doris versucht die große liebe zu
vergessen der alltag lenkt ab und sieht
für gott
aber das herz und gefühl blieben in der
vergangenheit
[Musik]
ähnlich groß der monika sie wohnt im
monat auf dem gleichen hof oder erich
sie für sind traum vom aufstieg wieder
zwischenzeitig sie moore geworden und
lebt in eine offene beziehung mit dem
mann ab haben das ist schon machen
einfach mal für mich ganz schön gesehen
dass das ganze eine andere mensch ist
also wirklich ganz anders wie drehen und
drehen sich gerade zwei neue mini mit
harter hand
herzig ihres leibes uhr die gerichtet
aber zehn sucht noch mehr ich bleibe da
der erich hess italien gehört monica zu
denken
wenn man anderen partner lehrt kennen
und man hätte erst die partnerschaft
habe nicht abgeschlossen
nicht wirklich verabschiedet denn ist es
ja was haben jedes sie und verarbeitet
ich hatte natürlich mit einer neuen frau
rbb wieder sachen verzählt foto monika
was sie nicht so toll gefunden habt dass
das ist normal höchstes maß aber
scheinbar ist das hat sie mir noch
gesagt das ist einfach erzählt sie
und so kurz dass der erich noch um
chitra sie unerwartet wieder monika vom
hofstaat
dann wurde mir plötzlich gegenüber
gestanden ist und die tür und freies
nach hof gemacht habe und dass natürlich
wieder sehr emotionalen moment gesehen
wunderbar ins see- und grad schön aber
alle fühlen sich sofort wieder druck sie
nicht merkt ja bedeutet ist genau der
richtige fragen
es ist die zweite chance für ihre liebe
geschenkt wird die ihnen bei demand
verletzungen überwindet akzeptieren dass
andere menschen im leben von partner ag
hält
schmerzhaft ich die erfahrung werde
falls sie und dass er mich nicht korrekt
waren die roten dass ich das war nicht
immer so
nach drei tagen sehr bestimmt und wenn
gc ist monika bereit mittels ghana sogar
zum täter zweimal mit dem erich sintra
ums leben
das einfache leben in der natur als
selbstversorger
[Musik]
wenn ich sport doch und ihre erste
gemeinsame kind oft welt das sind härte
aber glück lief ja trotzdem monique
rijks druck
so bin ich auch sitze ich das machen wir
nicht ob ich nach italien ich glaube ich
habe voll und ganz jetzt aber wenn sein
zug und den will ich mir das alles noch
mal neu überlegt an das passiert dass
ich mich den normalen entscheidet wurden
monika die abgeschiedenheit für sich und
ihre perspektive und reist zurück die
schweiz
fotos leitet sie amerika und
konfrontiert ihn mit ihrem entscheid um
zeitnah durch einen entscheid hoffe am
besten sieht es mal ab zwischenrufe und
lasse sich ein wunderschönes haus
gerettet und ich hatte vertragen 74 und
die kritiker mit kindern so herzlich
star mit der aber es ist einfach so
[Musik]
der traum vom ruf gern zurück
goldschmieds fußstetter hof das leben
als lehrer starter selbst versorgt jetzt
ist monika wurde erich vorstellt und ist
sehr spannend
natürlich kombiniert was ist nach
selbstverständlich mit mit dem mitreden
aber auch eine zeit mit das alles
dass das auch und gemehrt
[Musik]
sieht der mensch los sind 20 jahre
vergangen monika und erich und
unterdessen drei erwachsene jeans und es
groß sind
sie leben als schulrektor und
kindergärten retzlaff verpassen land
täter 17 es baut entreißt wie sie beide
stimmt
[Musik]
weißt du was ich bin überrascht
ihre liebesgeschichte von der sehnsucht
nach und die heißen sie ein land sucht
und seen zu finden
das ist mittlerweile beide bewusst ja
das möglich foto von dirk brandt risch
und dann aber also nur akzeptiert
sondern selber toll findet metallisches
vorentwicklung ich habe niemals einen
geheimen hat nie richtig wohl mehr mit
uns quasi das nach der disco oder mit
gewalt machen machen wir das mit kindern
gut machen wir's einfach stimmt und will
wie lebens von der nato ist und hebt das
haben sich wohl
[Musik]
claudia und pete der griechischen fähre
flirt wozu der große liebe worden ist
claudia hat am telefon schluss gemacht
dass titel lang still
[Musik]
aber ein schreibt claudia amm peter
brief und erklärte warum sie in
andernach gehabt
[Musik]
ich glaube traurig sei sie hat ihre
eigene wohnung kosovo als
arbeitskollegen und freunde kam aber am
morgen nach einem viererpack in ihrer
wohnung hat sie sich verständlich
erklären gefühlt und und richtig so dass
frau er noch einmal neu buchen
und genau das hätte peter claudia den
ort zurück schritte kann eigentlich
vorwürfe erwartet wonach die zum hier
machen wirklich vorwurfsvolle töne oder
so oder eben in briefen und überhaupt
nicht im gegenteil er hat großes
verständnis noch das heißt natürlich
dass ich ja schon großartig oder ja und
das hat mir natürlich dann wieder
gemacht
vor allem glaube sie ist gut drauf
die beiden treffen sich wieder
trotz verschiedener länder sprachen und
kulturen sind es jetzt sicher dass sie
zusammengehören
aber als hindernis blieb
ab geht sind andere liga bis in die
mutter hat andere pläne mit ihrem sohn
meine mutter hat ja irgendwann einmal
wirklich sehr dass gott wieder das ist
nicht nur ein flirt und ja halte dir die
typische südländischer tricks sehen wir
mal wie das halt dann in griechenland so
üblich ist dass die mitleid mit anderen
griechische mamas bei den daumen da
kandidatinnen präsentierten aus gutem
hause und einen guten job und so und ja
ich muss ja heute noch haben sie angst
um ihr seid ja nichts ohne den
[Gelächter]
kompromiss wird schwiegermutter die
beide hier ortet griechisch orthodox auf
samos und bin zwei mal auf mein
schicksal gut mit ihnen lebt findet
gerade war ihm ein job wie der schweiz
mit wohnen sie immer nachts winterthur
inzwischen dritte mit ihrer tochter
melina
[Musik]
da hätte man religiöse und loidl idee
ist einfach da ich eine gewisse skepsis
macht
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
sie geht
[Musik]
die beide sind glücklich und darum pc
niemals 2
[Musik]
kein tag war vergangen an dem ich nicht
an dich gedacht und dem ich mich nicht
fragte hast du wohl gerade machst
[Musik]
salzburg peter herrmann mühe kann somit
positiv fiel rede zum vertrag von
geschrieben
der einsame und lange nächte auf der
notrufzentrale verfasste polizist
gedicht und rumänen und amazon immer
wieder reizvoll sein werk user und
schickte dorißen brief und nutzt
gleichzeitig gelegenheit zum die frage
wie sie ihre gott
[Musik]
was ist damals in die ultramoderne sie
hat sich wieder getraut liebe doris
schreiber
wieder einmal hat er den verschickt also
weiteres neues bürger hat und da habe
ich den kunden so jetzt kann ich gehe
immer irgendwo abstellen sondern hat im
mikro- und hat eine geschrieben
die durch alkohol oder überflieger sind
ja genau
[Musik]
40 jahren zurückgehe von
freundschaftstreffen sich doris und der
hermann wieder
[Musik]
sehr wahrscheinlich da die wahre gefühl
zeigen dass staatsrechtler oder muscheln
die ich den aufgang
ich bin im training und hat in mir die
freiheit montag so und letzte gang ist
im herzen und im bestand
alle treffer und irgendwann einmal ist
es ein halter zur homo ist gegenseitig
also dürfe tauben in der flur geht und
dann ist das halt so mancher denkt doch
was unter eigentlich noch denkt er
eigentlich ist meine sache initiative
ergriffen und bissig einfach nehmen und
kalter hahn und ich bin im den hals
gefallen
gott sei dank ziel der schritt an die
mutige die mutigen davos
die beide sind seine frau zwinge zocker
am ort ihrer kindheit
wer stimme wieder erklären was das heißt
die beiden chefs von früher noch sind
sie zwei jahre als richtig
doris unter hermann holen was sie die
lange jahre vorher verpasst und
vermissten
[Musik]
in sure you say me softly da wo alles
angefangen hat 35 und die beide wieder
[Musik]
was macht die erste große liebe meine so
groß dass man sie begeistern sie vorher
noch schmetterlinge im bauch kam das
weiß ich was haben das wenig sie die
tiere klettern oder sich sehen oder wenn
sie mit mir geredet man sich natürlich
großes reich ist die familie oder und
das ist eben so dass einfach die teams
ein muster und ornamente was mir aber
auch große sicherheit sich so quasi zehn
babys das er immer wieder seine generäle
was mich sehr berührt hat das gedicht
oder sie beide gedicht und ich sehe ja
das bin ich und dass ich meine gedichte
malz verfasst werden
also ich mir auch klar wir dürfen das
immer beschäftigt hat und ihn durchs
ganze leben begleitet hat man würde ja
sagen zum schluss von den vielen tausend
euro für immer
konnte
du jedoch wirst in zukunft mein
wertvollstes sein
ich habe dich bitte lass mich nie mehr
allein ergibt sich im leben auch jede
wende
ich liebe dich mein schatz bis ans
lebensende
[Musik]